on aime les free certains sont même
prêts à rouler des kilomètres pour en
manger une barre mais voilà qu'on voit
de plus en plus de friteuse à air qui
semble cuire des frites aussi bonne avec
beaucoup moins de gains vraiment
pour commencer on a fait un test de bord
juste polis frites fraîches mais peut-on
avec un soupçon d'huile obtenir une
frite digne de ce nom
on dirait bien à en croire les images
sur les emballages
il existe plus d'une quarantaine de
friteuse à air sur le marché nous en
avons testé cinq de marques populaires
dont les prix varient de 140 à 330
dollars
et nous avons comparé les résultats à
ceux obtenus en utilisant un four
ordinaire un four à convection et une
friteuse à lui mais qu'est ce donc qu
une friteuse ar c'est juste un petit
faux à convection turbo et en plus il ya
un élément chauffant sur le dessus donc
irait dis donc c'est un peu comme un boy
la fonction grille quand la sueur
nouveau et il danse il ya beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup d'air qui circule très
vite et la radiation en plus donc le
produit la surface ça sèche donc color
plus vite avec une friteuse traditionnel
lorsqu'on submerge la pomme de terre
dont de l'huile à 190° on obtient une
frite grand campe à l'extérieur et
moelleuse à l'intérieur obtiendront nous
un résultat similaire avec les friteuses
ar c'est ce qu'on va voir
nous avons bien sûr suivi à la lettre
les instructions des fabricants tf1 on a
une demi heure de cuisson une demi heure
de cuisson c'est comparable aux autres
sont toujours autour de 25 35 minutes
est ce qu'on remarque c'est que le
produit est quand même assez parle c'est
pas un peu mou mou y'a pas beaucoup au
fait le poids de croustilles ans on va
le remettre à cuire encore emeril
lagasse lagacé là c'est vraiment m2
contenant ses spectaculaires
oui et on peut faire on va faire
beaucoup est ce que se dit docteur bon
déjà je la coloration et en avril
c'est joli c'est pas comme une
croustillante de frites dans l'huile
ça sèche affecte crunch j'ai
l'impression de manger une frite
congelés réchauffer au four traditionnel
c'est un produit qui aurait qu mais
c'est pas comme une friteuse bonnes
frites
on va regarder la héritage
même si la surface est plus petit et ici
on a quand même une assez belle la
coloration aussi ouais ça coûte un peu
sa main du script qui réchauffe
oui exactement
[Musique]
et belle coloration aussi avec la in
stone bolt ex après une trentaine de
minutes de cuisson on constate que
presque tous les appareils ont donné des
résultats comparables à ceux obtenus
avec le four à convection mathieu pélops
encore là on un peu la même sensation
mais le modèle tefal même avec deux fois
plus de temps cuisson n'a pas bien
colorer les fripes et donne un résultat
comparable au four traditionnel on est
rendu à presque 50 minutes
honnêtement jack sim à cela c'est le
résultat le moins intéressant conclusion
les appareils testés ne font donc rôtir
les frites avec un résultat comparable
un four domestique à convection et
malgré qu'ils emportent le nom ce ne
sont pas des friteuses à défaut d'être
des reines de la patate les friteuses r
nous ont par contre faire de délicieux
résultats avec de petites portions de
légumes comme des asperges des carottes
ou des panais qui même avec très peu
d'huile étaient colorés voir
caramélisées de bons résultats aussi
avec les produits congelés tous qui
peinez congés dans ce qu'on achète déjà
pré paris fonctionne très bien dans
livre to their mais fonctionne très bien
dans un four régulier et d'excellentes
performances avec les viandes crues les
ailes de poulet ça fonctionne très très
merveilleuse plus belle que dans mon
faux mais il ya un hic c'est sûr que
pour plus que deux personnes la friteuse
à air s'est vraiment passé trois quatre
cinq personnes ça me prendrait vraiment
un flot régulier si je reçois mes amis
pour le super bon je resterai pas faire
des ailes de poulet le porc tout le
monde musulman
et n'essayez pas de préparer tout ce qui
est illustré sur certaines bois et si je
vois comme espèce de crevettes panées je
vois des légumes tamboura je me dis je
peux face à dassa eh bien ce n'est pas
le cas voici le résultat de nos légumes
tour en résumé la majorité des appareils
sont faciles d'utilisation rapide et
performant pour réchauffer en gardant le
croustillant ou cuir certains types
d'aliments mais ces appareils occupe
beaucoup d'espacé sur le comptoir et
génère pas mal de bruit et de chaleur
malgré tout parmi les 5
notre expert a quand même une préférence
et opterait pour le enstone vortex dont
les faits l'autre contrôle est vraiment
enceinte la capacité très grande c'est
vraiment mon préféré c'est parmi les
moins chers
[Musique]